you take you know probably the worst
turban on Steve's kind of experience and
multiplied by about 10 and that's the
potential that we're going into that's
the voice of Justin Kibbey he's a pilot
my job title says hurricane hunter pilot
yeah he flies planes through hurricanes
it's all in the name of science
he works for NOAA the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration these
missions are for data gathering to track
and study hurricane paths and movements
but Justin Kibbey and I aren't talking
about data we're talking about what it
feels like to fly an airplane through a
hurricane
it starts to get cloudy and once you're
in the storm you'll start to hear rain
hitting the windscreen it can be very
loud it's surround you surrounded the
whole plane are the best we describe it
if you have ever lived in a house with a
tin roof it's hard to hold the
conversation inside these are the
conditions Hurricane Hunters fly through
every time they go on a mission because
the point of flying through a hurricane
is to fly through it and get to the eye
and he was telling me about the first
time he ever did that that was 2010
we're flying into hurricane Earl the
latest information we're getting about
Earl chap a hundred and thirty five
miles per hour and still getting
stronger and then I remember breaking
out into the eye of the storm everything
just kind of stopped everything always
stopped lighting stopped pitch-black out
you can see stars above you it was
really beautiful serene it's quiet and
it was a
holy [ __ ] was just what do we just do
what just happened and a bolt of
lightning lit up the entire outbound eye
wall where I could see it visually and
also oh man that's gonna be scary it was
a rough ride on the way out but I'll
never never forget it it was probably
one of the coolest that I've been on
[Music]
when we think about volcanoes we imagine
these eruptive hot violent gateways to
the center of the earth and I spoke to a
scientist who spends the night in them
my name is Ken Sims and I'm a professor
of isotope ecology at the University of
Miami Ken studies among other things
volcanoes and it's for a few reasons but
one in particular you can start to
forecast this likelihood for another
eruption to get his research data he has
to spend time in them sometimes over
night so we're talking about what it
feels like to spend the night in an
active volcano
you're in a big crater it's spectacular
this is like being in a deep deep canyon
except for now it's circular all the way
around you there's a lava lake below you
and the summit is above you volcanoes
have a particular smell because they're
full of gas those gases are very so
first so they smell I'm strong and
accurate they also have acids in them
and so they're toxic the air can be
dangerous to breathe in you know you
often times are wearing gas masks but
it's pretty hard to sleep with gas masks
and it's noisy it's echoey typically
you'll hear a scene instead of a
campfire there's an active lava lake but
looking at a lava lake is just
phenomenal that way it's mesmerizing
there's something about the red warm
glow that's unworldly there's a lot to
distract you from sleep but sim says
none of that matters you don't want to
go to it I mean this is how the Earth's
surface formed was from volcanoes and if
you're in the moment it's amazing that's
so cool
think of being in a freezer and then
somebody puts your face directly into a
big pile of wet ice you that's what it
feels like
I'm speaking to Lisa Kelly she's a scuba
diver with National Geographic and she
leads expeditions in Antarctica and the
arctic temperatures and Arctic waters
typically range between 25 and 35
degrees Fahrenheit because the waters
are so cold divers have to use special
gear this includes use of a dry suit
these suits
actually keep divers dry when they're
underwater I like to call it a
self-induced state of hypothermia really
because even though you're dry
you're still going to get cold and that
is such a shock on people's system
unfortunately there have been deaths due
to cardiac incident because of that
aside from the cold there are other
things that divers need to be on the
lookout for walrus polar bears animals
like killer whales reverberate sound we
call it singing it sounds like a gunshot
under water it can go right through you
but Lisa Kelly says that diving in the
Antarctic and the Arctic is an
unparalleled experience and it starts on
the boat that initial feeling when you
fall back in the water it's just the
sound of you breathing through your
regulator it suddenly becomes your own
little world all of a sudden all these
amazing colors start to pop out and it
really is a whole other universe and in
Antarctica you're there in a place where
possibly nobody has ever died before
[Music]
when we think of the ocean we think of
the beach but I'm speaking to one of a
handful of people who have been to the
deepest depths of our oceans
my name is Bruce Strickland and I am
currently the senior pilot and manager
of Alvin operations group at the Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institution
he pilots a submarine called Alvin and
he works with scientists to explore deep
ocean life and terrain our average depth
on most dive is between 2,500 and 3,000
meters that's almost 2 vertical miles
this is what it feels like to go 10,000
feet below the water surface we dive off
and down near the equator suit sunny and
early morning it's nice you'll dive in
the water and you hit a color of
turquoise that I have never been able to
see anywhere else
but that blue doesn't last long it's
easy to lose light within 5 to 10
minutes easy and you're left suspended
in seemingly black water the sub spend
the whole way down on the whole way up
but you don't even notice the only the
only way you can tell is you can look at
the compass and see us turning around
within that darkness small flashes
emerge these are from animals who live
at these extreme depths you hit lots of
bioluminescence the amount that you can
see outside is astounding and then you
hit the bottom when you get to the site
that you're headed to and you turn the
lights on there's a huge wow factor
there in particular areas with
geothermal vents or these underwater
geysers massive structures that rise
thousands of feet up towards the surface
the view at the front is astounding
because there's nothing like it anywhere
else on the planet nothing our
perspective is altered by our experience
because you can't go and look at the
ocean anymore and think of it just as
this endless flat surface of water you
have an understanding of what's
underneath
[Music]
when you're looking at some platforms
usually it's just water everywhere
which makes you feel really really tiny
jumping into this giant ocean I'm
Rachelle Simpson and I'm a world
champion cliff diver it's very similar
to Olympic diving the only difference is
at the end we're going to land on our
feet as I climb up on the platform's
easier to win blowing your New Year's
sometimes they're seagulls zooming
around my head here the announcer call
my name it's kind of like I'm going into
this hallway and this sounds totally
cutting out because that's when I'm
going into focus nice when I set my feet
and then my arms go up I count to three
and go your bodies on autopilot and your
brain is just sitting back watching
front somersault twist second somersault
right position actually when you hit the
water at first you don't notice anything
and then it starts all coming back you
create bubbles underneath the surface
and you feel those bubbles pushing you
back up to the surface credits cool
feeling actually and we come up take a
breath the air and the rush of
adrenaline it's like you've been holding
it off and not even breathing until you
hit that water each time I enter the
water
it's another successful moment of
convincing my brain to be something I'm
scared of but each time I get a sense of
empowerment when I overcome it I love it
[Applause]
[Music]